so predictably republicans right-wing
media extremists on the right
authoritarians uh the usual suspects are
furious about the student loan debt
forgiveness that joe biden is doing now
this is another great accomplishment for
joe biden and in the next story i'm
actually going to go through the
incredible two-month 180 arguably one of
the the greatest turnarounds in a
presidency
certainly that i've covered and i would
argue in decades in the united states
but before we get to that
one of the real reasons that republicans
are melting down and panicking over joe
biden student loan debt forgiveness that
was announced yesterday
is that on some level they realize
43 million people
directly benefit
and then their families their spouses
their parents who might be helping with
the payment whoever the children
everybody benefits indirectly as well
and republicans realize that this could
be really bad for them in the november
midterms but they have nothing else to
do
than to make outrageous claims about why
this is bad well this is unfair to
people who have paid their student loans
we talked about that in the last segment
this is a handout this teaches people
they don't have to be financially
responsible or whatever else the case
may be
and part of what's happening is they
know this is very bad for them let's
look at a couple of examples of this
here's fox news propagandist tucker
carlson whose lawyers uh have argued in
court that he's not really doing news
he's doing entertainment and nothing he
says should really be taken seriously
that's a legal defense to tucker
carlson's program um tucker carlson says
that the student debt relief is a form
of reparations being paid to drug
addicted robots who have no job
prospects wow
so when joe biden announced day that he
plans to cancel some of that debt the
obvious response would be to celebrate
the announcement but we didn't right
away oh instead we paused to learn the
details about what he was proposing
that's a habit we've picked up from
watching people like joe biden in action
over the past several years it's always
worth reading the fine print these are
the very same people after all who
decided it was a good idea somehow to
defund the police
they're the ones okay now remember
they haven't defunded the police
and as far as joe biden's concerned
he has nothing to do with police funding
i mean just it's just neither here nor
there it's a complete non-sequitur you
force the entire american population to
take an experimental covet vaccine even
when it became obvious that it didn't
work
these are the people who said okay and
again there's so much to that
the initial vaccine against the initial
variant was extremely effective at
preventing infection over time its
ability to prevent infection diminish
but its ability to prevent
serious covet death and hospitalization
was still good i mean all these one-line
lies require some time to unpack but
really this is about the student loan
debt forgiveness crack pipes to crack
addicts the ones who think 16 year olds
should vote in presidential elections
the ones who screamed at you about how
ukraine's borders are sacrosanct but
yours are racist
etc etc etc these are people in other
words with a long and public track
record of very bad ideas extraordinarily
bad ideas ideas so stupid you couldn't
make them up
so the question is is this idea
different we want it to be but
unfortunately it's not and here's how
you know it's not
colleges aren't refunding any of the
loan money
you are
you are but wait you say i didn't
defraud anyone
i didn't claim that a degree in
post-colonial liberation studies from
wesleyan would be worth anything
i didn't take 80 grand a year for
middle-class families in order to turn
their children into xanax addicted
robots with no job prospects
listen these are just xanax addicted
robots with no job prospects they don't
deserve the student loan forgiveness now
there's so many different ways to
respond to this
and as we've talked about earlier it's
good for the economy
for money to be going back into real
businesses
rather than just interest on student
loans paid to mega financial
corporations which people like tucker
carlson often criticize
but there's a bigger picture here which
is tucker correctly points out we have a
broken higher education system the the
other day
um i was calculating what was it we i
was calculating based on how much
uh based on how much my my girlfriend's
alma mater's
tuition went up from when she graduated
to now we were calculating that when our
daughter would be 18
it would be 203 000 a year if just it
kept growing at the same rate like
obviously something has to break it's a
completely broken system tucker is
correctly identifying that
um and you know what i have even said
before
there should be some consideration based
on your major
uh whether the cost of the education is
is worthwhile right i mean when i think
about any expense i think about what's
the value and if you're going into a
field where you are unlikely to really
make money then it's perfectly fair to
consider whether the cost to the
education makes sense there's a whole
bunch of things that go into that but
again this idea of the recipients aren't
deserving is just an it's the same way
they talk about any welfare program and
it's a it's a very broken and disturbing
way to talk about it now a couple other
examples of this here is uh dan bongino
talking to jesse waters on fox news
he says that the student loan debt
forgiveness is evidence of the collapse
of america still trying to get over this
whole thing because listen jesse if you
were um doing a tutorial on what the
collapse of great empires look like yeah
just pick up your phone start the video
camera because this is exactly what it
looks like and just leave it running
this is the movie this is the
autobiography of the autobiography of
the american empire collapsing before
our very eyes yep 10k
of student loan forgiveness for those
making under 125 000
and 20k for pell grant recipients
that's the end of american civilization
now of course the counterpoints are
just about every country in western and
northern europe
where they are flourishing
they are good business environments
people have health care the health care
is good education is good
uh quality of life is good life
expectancy is good and in many cases
they have college education paid through
taxation now here
government money for for the forgiveness
means it's taxpayer money that's
absolutely true
and it's really no different than the
taxpayer money directly paying for the
education in this case it didn't
directly pay for it now it's going to be
part of the forgiveness
it's not the indication of a collapsing
empire many of the best countries in the
world to live in have education paid for
through taxation now one more bongino
clip here he is
um
it's more kind of like lazy like these
people everybody's lazy according to
bungina what's happening here really has
me a little annoyed because there's this
thing an income repayment program you
know what it's called
it's called the freaking job and here's
how this works a job there's this thing
let me just do a demo for you all at
home okay there's this thing you have
it's called the ass right here the ass
okay and when the ass gets up out of the
seat and goes to work and you remove the
ass from the seat you get this thing
it's a four letter word called the job
some of you know joe biden will get the
joke
you get the job and then you pay back
the loan okay
so
first of all right wingers think that
that's like a thinker they see they
believe bungino is a thinker now
aside from the lazy narrative just being
it's a lazy narrative quite frankly it's
lazy to just do the lazy narrative
a lot of the people i don't know how old
he is but a lot of the people who say
just work and pay for school that's all
when they were in school
relative to income college was
exponentially cheaper it was orders of
magnitude cheaper the relationship fact
tom hartman has talked about on his
program how his wife louise
if i recall correctly basically waitress
to pay for college the idea now
that you could work like in food service
to pay for college
is absurd because the relationship
between the cost of college and the
minimum wage and the median wage has
gotten completely out of whack so these
people don't know what they're talking
about but they're certainly trying to
make you think that they do